hello I am Jake Roper from Vsauce I'm
fortunate enough to be here with Bill
Nye the Science Guy and we are here
because of 92nd Street wise seven days
of genius in collaboration with big
think thank you for being here oh no it
is I who must thank you oh it's great to
be here yes how do you see yourself
bringing out genius in in youth and kids
because you've done that for so long
really I think so I grew up with you and
look at me now yes Here I am a genius
no well you want people to try stuff you
want people to not be afraid to
experiment and so I always say about
science education it's empowering when
you learn about the world around you
learn about nature and then how you fit
in you'll try things and I think that's
really it's kind of how we got YouTube
and Big Think and the Internet is people
just trying stuff ways we're all just I
think as human beings just inherently
curious we want to find out oh I claim
I'll claim Jake that our ancestors who
were not curious aren't never became our
ancestors I got eliminated mm-hmm know
the human human curiosity is how you
discover things and that's how we
innovate that's what keeps humans in the
game I mean look we live all over the
world yeah
we're in Manhattan I know this is airing
in March was a cold winter several days
you wouldn't want to be outside without
some clothing and so that all comes from
being able to wander because you had the
equipment to try it and do you think at
any point that maybe our our curiosity
has dwindled a little bit well this is
everybody's concern in science education
if we can put a man on the moon why
can't we yeah why can't we address
climate change most of the patents that
are issued are issued to people under 26
years old oh wow
so that innovation comes especially when
you're young I mean there's the other
half are people over 26 all right but
it's an important thing to get people
excited about science and feeling that
they can create so when it comes to
informing and educating kids do you
think there is a divide between
discipline and play can they kind of go
together
well you want the right balance in the
same old thing let me tell you cannot
teach elementary school without recess
mmm I'm not kidding you ask any
elementary school teacher if you take
away recess thinking you're saving money
as the tax pay as a school board member
or whatever it is you're messing up no
kids you have to have recess and so what
you want is this balance between
creative time working on a project and
the discipline of learning things that
you have to know like three words
algebra wait that's one word algebra so
algebra is the single most reliable
indicator of whether or not you'll
pursue a career in math and science this
is to say it is not clear that it is
cause and effect it's not clear that
algebra causes you to accept science as
a career or embrace science as a career
but apparently and this is people
speculate this papers are written neuro
scientists go crazy for this you
thinking abstractly about numbers with
letters let's say helps you think
abstractly about all sorts of things and
to all of you out there who are trying
to learn algebra it you have to practice
I'm sorry man I did too
yeah I mean I was pretty good at it I
was not the world's best but you have
I'm sorry and comes to math you've got
to practice you have to memorize the
alphabet I'm sorry people it's so
talented
that's the balance you want and I think
what makes a good instructor a good
educator a good teacher is somebody who
has a sense of when to let kids mess
around and when to have them buckle down
mm-hmm easy for me to say was a good
point was an interesting thing with
specifically algebra even just with a
lot of the sciences that it's a physical
thing you're physically doing things via
typing numbers into account they're like
writing things down or grabbing a
compass out like you're actually using
your brains and your hands yeah so again
when you go with practice it is kind of
like learning the violin or playing a
sport isn't that you need to rehearse
you have to practice and practice yeah
and you have to accept as a student and
a teacher and a parent that there's just
times where you have to buckle down and
practice
yeah and there's other times where you
have to mess around you have to just try
things and that's really what has might
this is my interpretation what has kept
the United States in the game is the
education in the United States still
especially at the top levels still has
this combination of learning the facts
and just jump in and try it mm-hmm and
that's a we don't want to lose that
nobody in the world wants the u.s. to
lose that
you